your reaction on the repeater in
bachelor yeah I'm really happy for him
yeah I mean I had real feelings for him
and I know that he had real feelings for
me but ultimately when you care for
somebody you want them to find their
happiness so I think he's going to be a
great bachelor and is gonna make all
these girls really really happy and have
a really good great experience but
Hannah you topped the fence how can
Peter top of the windmill well I don't
know how he's gonna top the windmill me
I just think it may be a plane I don't
know what type of woman do you think
will be right for Peter knowing him mm I
think he needs somebody that is fun I
think he likes a strong woman but um
somebody close so awesome this chick is
it's a tough call your season cuz Mike
awesome - yeah you know I mean did you
were you leaning towards one of the
other four propeller no because I could
see either one of them being a great
bachelor and I feel like the people that
have been doing this for years and
making this these decisions make the
decisions for a reason and it's not that
one person's better than the other it's
just what do you think put Peter over
the edge
I think Peter really was heartbroken and
I break his heart and dang it yeah I
know I'm like my Pickers are really off
would you would you ever go back to any
of the exes at this point I really am
just focused on moving forward I think I
need to just you know focus on this
dancing to the spark I need to focus on
the sparkles right now and they need it
I need to fill my cup back up I think
I love it
[Music]